you got started in the martial arts
quite young yeah yeah how old were you
when you got started was uh
six you were six and and you got into
this business fairly early and i was
stunned that even in your first film
when you're a child
you're kicking ass in this movie we
found this movie shadow fury do you
remember shadow fury yes i do okay well
we remember it because we just found it
uh
wow and uh no it's it's you play an
eight-year-old who's trained to kill i'm
a i'm a clone yeah you're a clone yeah
and i'm yeah i'm trained to kill and
they put me up
up against this like six foot five bald
guy and i do these like nasty things
it's really embarrassing it's a fun
let's take a look at the clip because uh
you're a scary eight-year-old take a
look oh boy
[Music]
[Music]
christmas is our alpha
phase his nervous system has been
altered
he is impervious to pain
he knows no fear
you're eight i know you're eight and
it's totally convincing and i like that
you're also a nice kid right
i'm murdering you but i'm also a
pleasant child i can't believe you found
that oh no we're good uh
you so you have a lot in your repertoire
you've had to learn a lot of different
styles of fighting uh
to uh just to do the work that you do in
your different roles you so you know
boxing wrestling martial arts
i'm curious in your life tara lautner
you're you're what you're going to the
old folks bowling alley you cut down and
you know and and then you cut down like
a side street and there's some tough
thugs there and looks like you're in
trouble what skill would you use
in your in your real life to defend
yourself would you use the boxing the
wrestling or the martial arts um
that's a good question i mean if i found
you in a back alley
you know you're much bigger than me yes
you you if you got
much bigger i'm very fast very fast uh
i'm uh uh you don't know what kind of
skills i have i'm sure i i do not doubt
that i'm a little crazy too which helped
i mean yeah that's on my side in my i
wouldn't know what to expect i mean
right you might know what's gonna sit on
me or something like that no it wouldn't
be that there would just be some
long limbs that come at you from behind
and up and over got like spiderman
actually exactly i'm like doc ock i
might
so what do you do i i would want to keep
you at a distance for sure so i might
use some more kicks because if you got
close to me with those doc ock skills i
uh i would be done so kicking is a good
yeah that's what you'd go to yeah or i
get a little crazy too i mean sometimes
i don't think about what i'm doing and i
just like fly through the air and
surprise you
you can fly through the air
it's like you're on a wire it's like i'm
on a wire but there's no wire
you just go and go and go
wow i will not be attacking you anytime
soon i don't think i would come out very
well in that scenario
uh now i want to ask you about in this
movie abduction uh there's this
amazing there's a lot of amazing scenes
but it looks like you're doing your own
stunts there's actually a scene where
you're on the hood of a car at the very
beginning of the movie yeah and
unless i'm wrong you're really on this
hood of this car that's traveling very
fast it's true that was actually i mean
i love doing my own stunts it's probably
not smart but i i i love doing it and
that was the one stunt where they were
like you are absolutely not doing this
we are not putting our lead actor on the
hood of a truck flying down the road
yeah and i was i mean somehow i
convinced them to allow me to do it but
they're like fine you can do it but
we're only going to take it up to 20
miles an hour i'm like people people
people ever heard of method acting i
need to like feel the adrenaline that
this character is experiencing it's also
not going to be good if you're on the
hood of the car and a kid in a tricycle
is passing you
would not be good it's gonna undercut
the scene you know definitely but it was
it was great it was a lot of fun and i
got to do a lot of crazy stunts in this
one